annie pas besoin non plus de douaniers
pour nous rendre maintenant sur un
plateau voisin de notre plateau de 12h30
un plateau se tourne en ce moment un
film et qui donne l'occasion à yves
robert que l'on rentre en quelques fois
dans les couloirs
jean pierre richard et à mireille darc
de aussi se rencontrer pour travailler à
ce film qui s'appellera un grand blond
avec une chaussure noire à bien et c'est
claude couderc qui est allé sur les
lieux du tournage pour nous nous ne
suivons pas de vacances cet été pour me
reidar elle interprète les mata hari
burlesque et amoureuse amoureuse d'un
pierre richard plus naïfs et districts
que jamais dans le nouveau film de yves
robert
le grand blond avec une chaussure noire
les prises de vue en lieu au studio de
boulogne
j'ai invité quelques amis chez vous
pourriez faire un seul venir boire un
verre avec nous si mon adresse 85 rue
des plantes
son bien ce soit
yves robert explique son train solide
c'est la petite curieux mais qui
s'explique très simplement quand tu fais
des gravures
pourquoi un titre aussi long et nos deux
titres l'eau ont produites ou non nous
comme francis veber et moi qui avons
écrit ce scénario avons passé simplement
que c'est une manière de désigner
quelqu'un comme on dit le petit avec un
pardessus sagna aucune astuce derrière
il ya aucun aucune recherche
c'est la première fois que vous jouez
les mata hari j'ai pas pensé mais enfin
j'ai fait beaucoup de films policiers
donc oui c'est possible
cette espionne comment se porte votre
carrière me wade a très bien pourquoi
donc dans votre carrière comment ça se
fasse la vie encore mieux que ma
carrière
manger très personnelle diriez que ce
qui me touche moi qui m'intéresse saadi
je suis tout de même l'actualité comme
je suis la politique comme je suis la
bourse comme je suis les accidents je
suis très égoïste je dis il n'y a que
très peu de chose qui me touche vraiment
portrait de pierre richard s'en va quoi
tes grands yeux bleus des yeux d'enfants
surtout c'est ça qui est formidable
c'est 1-1 émerveillé naïf
thierry cela encore des malheurs au nom
des valeurs dont s'est terminée c'est
une période faste qui commence pour moi
qu'est ce qui se passe dans votre vie
vspace parce que je joue en tant
qu'acteur uniquement et que c'est pour
ça que je suis une période faste parce
que je suis décontracté ce que je peux
je n'ai plus qu'à penser qu'à qu'à moi
mais également pour partenaire mireille
da en vélo royaume la relation de la
balance si je puis dire ces deux mairies
d'arc elle fait partie des séries des
réseaus des réseaux clandestins et elle
est chargée me faire parler avec ses
arguments vous voyez tout de suite
lesquels voient priori j'ai rien pour
complaire aux plats une femme aussi
belle et elle est touchée par cette
innocence je crois qu elle vous attend
d'ailleurs sur le plateau tout de suite
non oui elle me crachent sais pas si
elle m'attend mais moi je suis pressé
d'y retourner
il